wo ist dein weg
hey schön dass ihr da seid alle darin
schön dich zu sehen vielen dank für die
einladung
pol dankeschön posten
was ist das dass das ist eine
sehenswürdigkeit in köln der kölner dom
warst du schon mal in köln kennst du
hast du noch nie in deutschland oder in
österreich oder in der schweiz
jetzt habe ich geschenkt aus köln
hamburg düsseldorf heidelberg und berlin
welche städte kennst du schon ich war
schon mal in hamburg und in köln in
heidelberg war ich noch nie nächste
woche fahre ich noch nicht was ist das
das ist das brandenburger tor eine
sehenswürdigkeit in berlin
kennst du berlin
nein aber nina war schon mal in berlin
und sebastian ihr wart schon mal in
berlin oder wir beide waren schon mal in
berlin ja wir haben sogar am
brandenburger tor
quito
alles gut
kein kommentar
komm ich bin ein spiel